I'm here with Bob from semi and today
we're talking all about knowledge traps
[Music]
Bob thank you so much for joining us
first things first what is a knowledge
graph so aknowledge graph tries to store
real world entities in a data object and
what we try to do with knowledge graphs
is to actually try to understand how the
real world works and drive knowledge
rather than just data from the way that
we store the information right now
that's different from a traditional
database which just stores information
yes so for example let's say that you
would store information about a movie
then there's all these relations that
you might have in your head about the
movie maybe actors or locations or
things that come to mind but if you
store that in a traditional database a
lot of context just gets lost
the it's just a database you could argue
that a database is just dumb it says
it's a dumb way of storing information
what you try to do with the knowledge
graph is to actually keep that
information and keep that context so
that you get a 360-degree overview of
what you're actually storing and that
people can query for the knowledge
rather than the raw data or information
so it sounds a lot like a traditional
graph database but you're also adding in
this knowledge or learning aspect yes
that's a good point so the graph part is
one could argue that everything that we
store has a relation to something else
so for example and back to the movies if
you would look at a movie a movie has
certain actors and they're born
somewhere and etcetera etc so that is
there's always a relation so that's
that's the graph part what the knowledge
part adds on top of that is that can we
actually try to derive knowledge from
that information so let's say that you
would have an actor who is born in Paris
but you know query for which actors come
from France
that'd actually under said oh wait now I
need to show this actor who's born in
Paris because there's related between
Paris and France
so we v8 is the product that you built
that is a knowledge graph
what makes we v8 special among knowledge
graphs yeah so I would argue that there
are there are three things there
so the first thing is is that we don't
store data objects in a in a traditional
way so in a in a table or in a
traditional graph we start in this space
and this is a semantic space so every
time when you add a new data object we
try to determine what does this data
object mean what does it represent in
the real world and we place that in a
space so for example with the actor
example if you would have an actor who
is born in Paris then it would be
closely related to France so that's how
we store this one the second thing that
we do is that we are completely API
based and that is also where we where we
stop if you will so we try to enable
others to build these semantic systems
and thirdly that is something that we
learned through the semantic aspect is
that we can now also do automatic
classification which basically means
that to stay in the with the example of
France that if you would have a country
with the name France and a city with the
name Paris the knowledge graph can
actually automatically drive hey wait a
second Paris is the capital of France
right so that learning aspect comes back
in how does it actually do the learning
I mean you're inserting the data by
using data objects but then it's got to
figure out how these are related yeah
that's a great question actually so the
interesting thing is like how do we
define learning so we have the the data
science aspect of learning but we also
have the the engineering aspect of
learning and one of the problems that we
wanted to solve is that every time when
you add a new that object we didn't want
to retrain the machine learning model
because you know it now takes about 48
hours to train so just imagine if you
want to add a thousand data objects
that's what that's under one so what we
learned was that the machine model that
we use has all these vector positions so
those are representations of concepts in
that space and what we do is that the
moment that you add data we try to
algorithmically determine where to place
it in this space so our learning if you
will is not necessarily retraining it's
just trying to understand where do we
need to place this data object in the
space which makes it very fast from an
engineering perspective which results in
a better UX so a user doesn't really
notice that they are
with a database also add a solution that
incorporates both the machine learning
model and a and a storage mechanism yeah
so how does it actually do I mean you
you have the data you're able to add it
in at figures of the new things but
without retraining it seems very hard
that it would be able to learn these new
properties yeah so there there are three
ways how we can do it so we have the
out-of-the-box knowledge which we like
to call the common knowledge so we train
it on open datasets so in English for
example think about Wikipedia a
dictionary but also scientific articles
etc so that's what we like to call the
common knowledge now you can do two
things so there might be a situation
where you have a very specific domain
knowledge that you want to add sort of
think about use cases in banking oil and
gas industry healthcare etc so what you
can do through the restful api you can
literally add it in natural language so
you can say I'm gonna now teach you a
concept these are the words of the
concepts and this is the description in
common knowledge because if you think
how au9 learn new words that's how we do
it we were two children we explain in
common language new concepts so what
happens under the hood is that we take
that concept in the description we
calculate a new position in that vector
space and that's right that new concept
lives so if you know start to add data
objects that talk about that concept
that's how we give it its semantic
understanding so you're able to kind of
teach it the new concepts and then it
makes those new associations without
having to do this new layer of
retraining basically exactly because we
wanted to have this this this UX aspect
is number one for us and then speed
plays a role so how fast can we do this
and that's the beautiful thing again of
that vectorization of concepts and words
because we can calculate with it which
means it's fast so what's the case where
a knowledge graph might not be a good
solution so for example if you have a
lot of streaming data or if you have a
lot of logs for example that you need to
search through fast what we see in
practices that's often you have a
traditional database and in a knowledge
graph and they they live you know
together and you solve problems together
so or for example transactions at a bank
then you you know you want to store them
in it
transactional fashion but if you don't
want to search through them or find
specific things then that's where the
knowledge graph comes in and takes that
information and stores it in a different
way right so this isn't supposed to
replace databases out there as a whole
but it's a new layer of looking at your
data
yes that's indeed what I would argue
it's just a completely different way of
looking at data however I would like to
say though if people would like to
change their data infrastructure with
vv8 I'll go for it well it's really
exciting to hear about the space so
thank you very much for coming in Bob
thank you